[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 22 novembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de tv 78
c'est le tour d'horizon de l'actualité
locale en 26 minutes tout de suite les
titres de cette édition les fêtes de fin
d'année arrivent à grands pas les
décorations de noël
elles sont déjà en place dans plusieurs
communes yvelinoise à montigny le
bretonneux l'installation a débuté
depuis le mois d'octobre 240 motifs sont
répartis dans toute la ville invité de
ce journal stéphane cartwright a pris
cette année la direction d'exploitation
sportif du vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines un équipement
qui coûte cher à l'agglomération est
d'après le dernier rapport d'activité
nous parlerons des nouvelles stratégies
pour l'enceinte
enfin ce franco cubain multiplie les
records en apnée andy cabreira avila
maîtres nageurs au centre aquatique de
saint cyr l'école et il se mobilise
souvent pour la bonne cause et d un
enfant malade à l'occasion du téléthon
ou encore pour sensibiliser à la
pollution d'aisance des océans c'est le
portrait de la semaine
et puis il rejoindra en plateau karl
olive maire de poissy qui était à
l'élysée hier à la rencontre des manuels
macron qui invitait 2000 élus
karl olive qui est le co auteur
également d'un livre sur les clés de la
réussite et de la confiance en soi c'est
à la fin de ce journal
l'actualité du jour d'abord en bref le
siège de ce groupe automobile est
implantée à voisins le bretonneux le
siège europe ouest nissan a décidé de
révoquer son président carlos ghosn le
conseil d'administration de la marque
asiatique la voter aujourd'hui pour
rappel le patron de l'alliance renault
nissan mitsubishi est suspecté au japon
de fraude fiscale et d'abus de biens
sociaux
il y est retenu en garde à vue nissan
assure pour autant que la sphère ne
remet pas en cause le partenariat et
d'alliance avec renault présent
notamment dans les yvelines à aiguilles
en cours et flins 50 millions d'euros
c'est le montant total des subventions
votées hier par le conseil régional
d'île de france pour les vies les
yvelinois 76 communes du département
vont bénéficier de ce soutien financier
dans plusieurs domaines et l'encours
villepreux et voisins le bretonneux vont
être accompagnés dans l'aménagement de
lieux naturels une aide également
pour la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines afin de la dé saturer pour les
lycées l'ile-de-france des blocs 475
mille euros pour montigny le bretonneux
et rap notamment pour les travaux
d'entretien et la lutte contre le
décrochage scolaire
enfin subventions aussi pour des
logements sociaux c'est le cas par
exemple pour maurepas elles ont déjà
pris place dans les rues à un peu plus
d'un mois des fêtes de noël les
illuminations ont été installés par de
nombreuses communes c'est le cas à
montigny le bretonneux ou une société
les places depuis le mois d'octobre
patrick jacques de dixmude et mélanie
poké la voix de marie demiap ishino des
milliers de leds qui à la nuit tombée se
parent de couleurs comme de nombreuses
villes montigny le bretonneux n'a pas
attendu le mois de décembre pour les
installer on n'a pas en interne le
personnel et le matériel nécessaire à la
pauvre qui doit se faire sur un laps de
temps très court on a démarré en octobre
il faut que ça soit fini pour le 29
novembre juste avant le week-end du
marché noël c'est le marché noël qui
donne le top de la mise en place pour
proposer des décorations différent
chaque année la commune les loups à une
société extérieure pour un coût de 100
milles aux 240 motifs sont répartis dans
toute la ville il nous reste quelques
motifs dont les motifs 30 et en trois
dimensions qui seront installés sur sur
l'avenue du pas du lac qui au niveau du
rond point vers skywest et un niveau de
l'hôtel de ville tous les quartiers sont
sont desservis les laisse les centres
commerciaux on lé byin bien sûr les nos
bâtiments publics l'hôtel de ville en
priorité plus que quelques jours
d'installation et les décorations
illumineront les soirées unis monteyne
jusqu'à la fin des fêtes à versailles
après le succès du comptoir de noël à
l'orangerie du château l'année dernière
celui ci se déplace au domaine de madame
elisabeth pour la première fois et voit
les choses en grand les 1er et 2
décembre une quarantaine d'exposants
vont s'installer dans une halle de 500
m² pour faire découvrir leurs produits
reportage de marie l'ania pishin la
magie de noël arrive au domaine de
madame elisabeth les 1er et 2 décembre
le département des yvelines fait
installer un comptoir de noël et de
multiples animations
le projet était présenté mercredi 21
novembre
en conférence de presse
c'est aussi l'occasion de rappeler à nos
concitoyens que le département est très
présent dans leur vie quotidienne et qu'
il se préoccupe d'eux et qu'ils
participent à leur peine sommes en
charge de responsabilité sociale
et puis aussi à leur joie comme cette
période de noël 500 m² de halle couverte
et chauffée seront installés une
quarantaine d'exposants et présenteront
des produits de qualité
ce marché de noël est pensé dans un
souci une réduction des emballages et en
faveur des circuits courts on a voulu
travailler avec l'intégrité des
commerçants qui vont venir pour avoir
une relation qui se crée aussi avoir
tout ce qui est éloquent durable donc
pas de produits plastiques travailler
sur du recyclable et c'est plus qu'un
circuit de saveurs le comptoir de noël
se veut comme une attraction familiale
ateliers créatifs cinéma de plein air
avec des plaids et tours de magie de
nombreuses animations seront proposées
quant à l'ancienne demeure de la soeur
de louis saez son rez-de-chaussée sera
transformé en véritable maison de noël
sur ce salon vous êtes demandés
actuellement dans sa salle de musique où
on pourra écouter des chants de noël et
en déambulant dans les restes des salons
on pourra découvrir l'art de la table
donc une arts de la table festive
comment décorer sa table pour noël et le
salon du père noël bien entendu parce
que tout comptoir de noël août au marché
noir elle a besoin d'un perdrait une
balade familiale pour patienter avant
les fêtes de fin d'année à guyancourt
l'aménagement du quartier du pont du
rotois se poursuit ce jeudi a été posée
la première pierre symbolique d'un
projet novateur de 84 logements à
vocation sociale coucou nage sera l'une
des premières résidences
intergénérationnelles en france elle est
destinée à accueillir des personnes
âgées mais aussi des actifs
objectif améliorer la qualité de vie des
seniors souvent en perte de lien social
au rez de chaussée se trouvera par
exemple une maison des projets un point
central de la résidence pour se
rencontrer partager et discuter ou
encore cuisiner ensemble livraison
prévue en juillet 2019
le dernier conseil communautaire de
saint quentin en yvelines s'est déroulée
jeudi dernier à trappes notre
journaliste michael et demi d'euros
étaient sur place bonsoir bonsoir
il était question de l'orientation
budgétaire pour l'année et 2019 et
notamment de la dette
oui effectivement grégory les derniers
chiffres sont plutôt rassurants pour
saint quentin en yvelines
l'intercommunalité affiché à aurait au
1er janvier 2019 sur le budget principal
un désendettement de 16 millions d'euros
réalisée sur la gestion de l'année 2018
un chiffre supérieur aux engagements du
pacte financier de 4 millions d'euros
on écoute le président de saint quentin
en yvelines jean michel fourgous au
micro de tv 68
on a quand même baissé de plus de 80
millions la dette ce qui est
exceptionnel et c'est ces mesures
exceptionnelles déjà que qui nous ont
permis de remonter notre note sandrine
course et qui nous a donné la note de ac
était une des meilleures notes
bien sûr en gestion des collectivités et
légalement eu un coup de projecteur sur
un cinéma le signer cet appel en cours
et là aussi les chiffres sont
encourageants après les travaux de
rénovation et sa réouverture en 2013 le
ciné 7 confirme sa bonne dynamique et
réalise sa plus belle année
d'exploitation je vous donne les
chiffres une fréquentation en hausse de
2,34 pour cent pour atteindre plus de
109 mille entrées sur un an le chiffre
d'affaires net est lui à supérieure à
530 5000 euros dont 467 69 7000 euros de
billetterie en écoute jean michel
fourgous un bon équilibre
faut dire que ce cinéma aujourd'hui la
quasi ont les mêmes qualités qu'un grand
cinéma sur les champs-elysées il a la
même qualité de son la même qualité
d'image le même confort ça coûtait cher
d'ailleurs à être rénové mais
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui un pôle culturel est qu à l
encours qui est quand même très fort
mais enfin il était question pendant
cette séance de l'enceinte du vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
là par contre les chiffres sont moins
bons le rapport d'activité de vélo
police pour l'année 2010 est a été à
dévoiler la structure a accueilli plus
de 35000 personnes sur des activités à
titre commercial comme des séminaires
des baptêmes sur piste ou encore des
projets événementiels les activités
liées à la présence des équipes de
france de cyclisme ont quant à elles
généré à 6060 visiteurs pas suffisant
pour être bénéficiaire la structure
affiche un résultat d'exploitation en
déficit de six cent cinquante trois
mille euros
des chiffres qui ne rassure pas à 50 ans
n'y fit bien sûr qu'il faut donner il
faut le demander plus c'est pour ça
qu'on a changé d'ailleurs l'opérateur
puisqu'on prend l'ucp amène à partir du
1er janvier 2018
bien sûr que c'est un c'est un opérateur
beaucoup plus actif dans les événements
sportifs dans l'est dans le réseau
donc voilà on a pris quelqu'un qui est
comme une autorité plus forte que donc
d'autres autres opérateurs pour
augmenter la rentabilité
bien sûr de ce vélodrome lui cpa et
l'union nationale des centres sportifs
en plein air qui gère déjà à des
piscines des centres équestres et des
abattis noir lui cpa s'occupera de la
partie événementielle
merci michael pour cette chronique
justement pour parler de la nouvelle des
nouvelles stratégies mises en place au
vélodrome pour son développement
stéphane tertrais bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le directeur d'exploitation du
vélodrome alors vous avez pris vos
fonctions cet été michael qu'il a dit
c'est un équipement qui coûtent trop
cher aux yeux de l'agglomération déjà
une réaction sur sur ce sujet bas-côté
déjà vous dire ma fierté mois l'honneur
que j'ai de travailler au sein du
vélodrome
c'est un magnifique et équipements et
travailler je suis ta montini donc
c'est un équipement qui est que je
connais bien et pour moi c'est vraiment
une grande fierté d'y travailler aux
côtés de la fédération française de
cyclisme qui est bien sûr le partenaire
privilégié au vélodrome j'ai entendu
effectivement et
et pris connaissance des chiffres que
vous avez cités ce qui est intéressant
est ce que je vous explique et c'est
effectivement le projet de l'exploitant
dans cette enceinte exploitants à une
partie ne représente pas l'ensemble du
projet du vélodrome
l'exploitant a un rôle effectivement
d'animations commerciales et sportives
et effectivement si vous m'en donnez
l'occasion jeu avec plaisir je vais vous
expliquer un peu ce qu'on compte faire
et ce qu'on a déjà fait depuis depuis
cet été
non michael ossi l'adil ucpa reprend la
partie événementielle en charge qu'est
ce que ça change concrètement pour pour
ce vélodrome nationale alors d'abord
leader déjà de dire que que lui cpa et
s'inscrit totalement dans le projet
global du vélodrome
tel que l'a souhaité l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
avec ce contrat qui a été signé en 2009
donc on est dans cette continuité et je
dirais que on a quatre dans notre
ambition dans notre projet on a quatre
points qu'on souhaite développer d'abord
faire en sorte que ce lieu soit le lieu
d'un projet éducatif et sportif
c'est peut-être la touche ou cpa quand
on va petit à petit déployée si vous me
permettez je reviendrai sur cet aspect
là donc un lieu d'un projet éducatif et
sportif
ensuite un lieu accueillant et ouvert à
tous pareils drames qui profite à tous
les saint quentinois aux franciliens de
ça c'est important de continuer à ouvrir
le lieu
deuxième point est troisième point est
lié au service de tous les acteurs du
territoire c'est-à-dire autant sportif
que économique
je vous expliquer ce qu'on pense qu'on a
déjà commencé à mettre en place dans la
continuité également et enfin un lieu
qui soit un lieu de rayonnement national
et international pour pour
l'agglomération pour les saint
quentinois donc pour commencer à gérer
sur le projet purement éducatif et
sportif
qu'est ce qui a déjà commencé et qu'est
ce qui se fait depuis cet été on a signé
grâce à la passion et l'engagement d'un
professeur d'éducation sportive du
collège de la couldre on a signé une
convention entre le vélodrome la s et la
section sportive du collège de la
couldre et du lycée descartes pour
réserver des créneaux
à cette section sportive donc à cinq
heures par semaine au vélodrome
donc ça c'est le nom de ce projet c'est
l'objectif voilà c'est nouveau et je
dirais que c'est parti et donc c'est
vraiment du scolaire donc c'est à côté
de l'élite du cyclisme c'est une
quarantaine de jeunes qui vont pouvoir
venir toutes les semaines et toute
l'année
faire du cyclisme piste et bmx ça c'est
une première une première action une
deuxième action ce sont des stages on va
développer pendant les vacances
scolaires des stages donc à destination
des jeunes de 10 à 14 ans ça va
commencer au moins c'est un pan des
vacances de février mais que les gens
pouvoir s'inscrire très bientôt des
stages qui seront découvertes vélo piste
bmx vtt dont bien sûr autour du vélo
mais peut-être aussi d'autres d'auto
type d'activité donc ça démarre en
février
rendez vous sur le site internet pour
s'inscrire un mot sur la fréquentation
il ya quarante et un mille cinq cent
quarante personnes qui sont venus au
vélodrome en 2010 est l'objectif c'est
de faire mieux vous disiez l'ouvrir
alors est davantage de saint quentinois
peu tel aviv et doit absolument en fait
ce qu'on a commencé à faire mes skis
étaient déjà engagés 1
est ce qu'on a fait avec avec
l'agglomération c'est ouvrir un maximum
l'enceinte donc qu'est ce qui s'est
passé même depuis cet été
en juin le 23 juin on a réalisé la
journée olympique
ouvert à tous activité gratuite le 15
juillet bien sûr on a ouvert le
vélodrome pour la retransmission de la
finale de la coupe du monde
six mille personnes décider en deux
jours c'était un moment j'ai ré de
festif incroyable justement de gros
événements comme celui-là pour pour
booster la fréquentation du biodôme
absolument alors qu'est-ce qu'on le 15
septembre on a fait une journée du
patrimoine classique et une grande
journée portes ouvertes où on a eu près
de 1000 personnes découvertes
d'activités sportives également animé
par des d'ailleurs les équipes du
vélodrome et demie chez p 1 et pas plus
tard que la semaine dernière donc
samedi dernier le 17 novembre on a
organisé au sein du vélodrome
un gala gallas tard en piste c'était une
première avec donc les équipes et
c'était un gala ouvert vraiment à tous
et qui rassemblait à la fois du sport
dédé cycliste de grande renommée pistes
et routes et qu'interface tiff c'était
plutôt sur un mode routeur tainment est
dans quelque chose de cette génération à
quoi va attendre le vélodrome dans les
prochaines années sera la dernière
question ce qu'on arrive à la fin de cet
entretien d'accord disons que ce sont
des ddd concept que l'on doit développer
pour effectivement que à côté j'irai de
l'aspect compétition est un aspect
commercial aussi le gros des visiteurs
en 2007 sont venus sur des événements de
ce type alors les séminaires il ya
l'aspect gérer sportif ya l'aspect be to
be et je dirais séminaires d'entreprises
qui est extrêmement important et donc
c'est ce savant mixte s'est-elle chimie
entre le sport de compétition avec la
fédération française de cyclisme
le sport amateur les entreprises donc à
un carrefour est un lieu de rencontre où
effectivement on espère qu'il ya encore
beaucoup de monde qui viennent il y aura
aussi forcément cette locomotive djo en
2024 avec des épreuves organisées au
sein de ce vélodrome merci à stéphane
tertrais d'avoir été avec nous au
directeur d'exploitation du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines retrouvez
toute l'actualité de l'enceinte sur le
site internet militant représentations
jusqu'à ce soir au théâtre national pour
le livre de ma mère patrick timsit est
allé à la rencontre des étudiants
une centaine d'étudiants de l'université
versailles saint quentin une
conversation public à la bibliothèque
universitaire de guyancourt à propos de
son spectacle adapté de l'oeuvre
d'albert cohen
le comédien était l'invité des master 2
administration culturels publics et
privés les propos sont recueillis par
michael et demi d'euros c'est forcément
un rendez vous de bonheur c'est c'est
l'occasion de parler de quelque chose
qu'on aime
on n'est pas du tout dans un dans une
démarche de promo de ses c'est un
rendez-vous de plaisir donc après je ne
me prépare pas je suis ouvert et à
l'écouté
c'est une grande figure aussi le monde
théâtral donc je suis très heureux et
normand les participer et de le voir en
direct c'est impressionnant parce qu'un
acteur comme sa pensée fait plaisir qui
viennent pour enfin pouvoir sont sans
public et c'est cool je vous propose à
présent de vous équiper de votre masque
et tuba pour le reportage qui va suivre
andy cabreira à vilain franco-cubain de
46 ans maître nageur de
saint-cyr-l'ecole accumule lé record en
apnée pour la bonne cause une discipline
qu'il pratique avec passion depuis son
enfance c'est le portrait de la semaine
par michael et demi d'euros et patrick
jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
gérer son souffle ses émotions pour
repousser toujours plus ses limites
le quotidien dandy cabreira avila le
franco cubain de 46 ans est considéré
comme l'un des meilleurs apnéistes de
france une discipline qu'il pratique à
la piscine de saint cyr l'école alors je
m'entraîne beaucoup à sec c'est derrière
humeur soit sur la chaise de son verre
sur la piscine et pendant qu'il
surveille les clients je fais ça voilà
lieu blog ma respiration ou minutes aux
ministres demain traîne aussi dans l'eau
à l'agent d une ou deux fois par semaine
le sportif réalise aujourd'hui des
records à couper le souffle
et à chaque fois pour la bonne cause en
2016 pendant six heures on dirait ali
694 longueur en apnée pour récolter des
fonds pour une enfant malade en 2017 il
passe 24 heures dans l'eau pour le
téléthon les sports ça nous permettre de
dépasser nos limites
mais si en même temps en parallèle les
dépassement de soi il ya aussi on cause
pour laquelle nous tient à coeur et on
se dépasse 50 plus émérites des records
toujours plus fou que ce maître nageur
imagine chez lui aux essarts-le-roi sur
les murs de son appartement la mer
encore et toujours cuba et bien sûr les
pneus alors ici ses membres jeudi par là
dit il prend des souvenirs que j'ai mais
si sûr à l'entrée chez moi sont des
choses qui me tient très à coeur
ici c'est un mois à cuba à la pompe
viril à mon stage ça fait il y aurait 20
ans j'ai toujours amoureux de la nature
et les défend la médaille de la des
plantes de leur médaille d'honneur de la
ville d'essentiel écoles ces espèces des
reconnaissances pour l'aragon ford et
tout ce que les faire à bessines
c'est ici également que le sportif cache
son plus précieux trésor celui qui lui a
permis de baigner dans cette passion
c'est petit livre je tiens mon plus beau
coup à ses livres voilà et de la colère
quand j'avais 4 ans 1974 à l'école à la
biotech et parle et 20 conte l'histoire
d'un petit enfant
il raconte tout ce qu'ils voient à la
mer donc depuis l'âge de 4 ans j'ai
découvert qu est ce que vous voulez
faire dammarie ces extraits font
doucement donc à 80 on va faire
rixheim couvrir la mer jusqu'aujourd'hui
la mer et la protection des animaux
marins des thèmes toujours plus chère à
andy pour défendre cette cause l'athlète
réalisera en février prochain défi passé
plus de deux heures 42 en apnée pendant
trois heures et tout cela avec un
déguisement de dauphins des parcs
aquatiques ont adressé les dauphins et
ses dauphins ont amené dernière des
clous nss clave pour servir les plats ca
de l'ordre des causes qui devrait amener
andy a replongé pour de nouveaux records
dans les prochaines années au moins
jusqu'à ses 90 ans
la remontée à la surface attendra avant
de refermer ce journal un invité m'a
rejoint en plateau bonsoir car le lièvre
bonsoir oui mr les républicains de
poissy vice président du conseil
départemental vous allez nous parler de
votre livre sorti en septembre juste
avant vous faisiez partie des 2000 mère
reçu hier à l'elysée par emmanuel macron
le président de la république qui n'a
pas souhaité cette année se rendre au
congrès des maires dans son discours le
président de la république a dit sa
volonté de dialoguer avec les élus
notamment sur des sujets comme la
réforme fiscale
quelles questions vous avez pu lui poser
hier j'ai demandé au président de la
république si on était véritablement
dans le contrat gagnant gagnant sur
lequel il s'était engagé pendant la
campagne présidentielle
gagnant gagnant parce que il faut
désendetter notre pays 2300 milliards de
dette
évidemment est bien sûr possible par
exemple 40000 habitants à peu près 1000
agents à l'époque et 93 millions de
budget ici en commune de la cité saint
louis mais nous avons réalisé 5 millions
d'euros d'économies ce qui m'a permis de
ne pas augmenter la pression fiscale
d'avoir le même niveau de service à la
population et le même niveau
d'investissement pour autant ma dotation
globale de fonctionnement continue de
diminuer
emma péréquation c'est à dire ce fonds
qui est donnée aux collectivités qui
sont mal en point continue d'augmenter
et donc je ne trouve pas où est le
contrat gagnant gagnant
c'est la question que j'ai posée au
présent république est-ce qui vous a
rassuré du coup en tout cas il a convenu
qu'il y avait une incohérence par
rapport à ça je veux pas un seul instant
qu'ils edouard philippe avec lequel je
vais déjeuner demain le premier ministre
puisse effectivement regarder de plus
près parce que c'est pas un bon signe
qu'on envoie moi des prime aux mauvais
élèves j'ai jamais connu ça ni dans
l'entreprise et n'y a ni à l'école ni à
la fin
vous êtes venu en plateau avec un
exemplaire du livre que vous avez publié
en septembre chez balland rendre
possible l'impossible c'est un livre
coécrit avec arnaud bochu robert qui est
une série d'entretiens de sportifs de
haut niveau grands patrons aventuriers
journalistes qui ont su se dépasser
libre leurs clés de la réussite et de la
confiance en soi
d'ailleurs la préface de ce livre est
signé du président de la république
emmanuel macron pourquoi est ce qu'il a
il a rendu en quelque sorte possible
l'impossible en devenant président de la
république alors à clémence est un maire
républicain qui qui vous parle et qu'il
a écrit simplement quand on regarde
l'histoire faut bien reconnaître que
emmanuel macron lorsqu'ils quittent le
gouvernement
et qui dit je vais aller et je vais
aller jusqu'au bout il rend possible un
possible parce qu'à l'époque d'abord
pardon de le dire
peu de personnes le connaissent comme il
l'est connus aujourd'hui
peu de personne ne croit en lui à gauche
comme à droite on dit que ça va faire
pschitt et à l'arrivée devient président
la république
il fait même mieux un peu comme au
bowling il fait strike y a plus de
quille du tout sur le jeu à la fois à
gauche sans paraître clia gauche mais
aussi à droite mais il a totalement fait
exploser les codes donc il a rendu
possible l'impossible et moi ce qui m'a
plu c'est cette détermination
comment j'ai fait je lui ai envoyé un
message à 11 heures le soir il m'a
répondu à quatre heures du matin pour me
dire ok banco on y va venez me voir et
je ferai cette préface alors dans
l'avant propos de cet ouvrage est
indiquée rendre possible l'impossible
n'est pas une utopie
c'est un appel d'exemplarité offert à
tout à chacun sa veut dire que la
réussite est là à portée de tout le
monde
oui je pense que rien est impossible
c'est un petit peu la conclusion que
nous formons avec arnaud bouche sur
berck vous l'avez dit qu est chercheur
associé à cette à cet ouvrage
oui je pense que les principales
barrières que nous nous mettons ce sont
celles même que nous avons finalement en
tête
il n'y a rien d'impossible et on voit à
travers par exemple philippe croizon qui
est ce sportif de haut niveau qui
malheureusement à la suite d'un accident
électrique a perdu l'usagé et des bras
et des jambes qu'ils traversent la
manche
si ça il n'y a pas un exploit et une
détermination c'est juste exceptionnel
je peux aussi également vous parler de
zahia ziouani qui est la première femme
chef d'orchestre qui toute sa vie a été
stigmatisé d'abord par rapport à son
origine sociale et aussi par rapport à
son statut de femme
aujourd'hui elle est connue dans le
monde entier et nous avons pris seize
portraits
je pourrais vous citer également claude
bébéar le fondateur du groupe axa qui va
manger axa en trois jours avec une
petite société d'assurance qu'il avait
lui-même créé et qui dit plus l'obstacle
et au plus j'ai envie de le franchir
ellis clé de la réussite c'est quoi
c'est le travail la confiance en soi
d'abord c'est la confiance en soi alors
justement quand les jeunes viennent nous
voir et à qui on dit ayez confiance en
vous oui ok monsieur ça signifie quoi
avoir confiance
les recettes sont ici nous avons des
clés de la performance et on s'aperçoit
qu'il y a de la détermination qu'il y
ait de la motivation et qui a aussi
cette faculté à rester totalement
inodore incolore à toutes les critiques
à ce titre là il ya un bel exemple
didier deschamps didier deschamps qui
alors lui on parle souvent de chat noir
aura été la patte de lapin porte bonheur
tout au long de sa carrière telle gagner
la coupe du monde noir et cx l'europe
champion du monde en tant que joueur
champion du monde en tant que
sélectionneur et killian mba paix dont
on dit qu'il a une énorme mature et
maturité pardon avec ses dix neuf ans mb
entretien 2.0 d'ailleurs j'ai fait un
entretien 2.0 avec arnaud avec avec
quidam qui dit j'ai toujours su ce que
je voulais les gens disent que c'est de
la maturité moi je ne le crois pas je
respecte le plan que je me suis fixé
et puis souvent grégory danser dans ses
portraits que nous nous avons dressé
on s'aperçoit que toutes ces
personnes-là communique sur les
solutions jamais sur les problèmes
comment vous les avez choisi justement
ses portes et on peut citer aussi dorine
bourneton qui est la première femme
handicapée à avoir été voilà qu'il est
devenu pilote de voltige
comment vous vous avez identifié d'abord
on a regardé leur biographie
et ce sont des exemples pour pour nous
autres chacune et chacun des français va
se retrouver dans dans ses portraits que
ce soit ma paie que ce soit serge
klarsfeld
hervé mathoux le journaliste je le
disais tout à l'heure il a belle
autissier et puis par exemple quelqu'un
comme jean louis etienne que vous
connaissez qui est explorateurs il sera
d'ailleurs à poissy le mardi 27 novembre
pour nous présenter son nouveau son
nouveau grand défi qui est un polar pod
est un immense bateau qui lui
david n'ont pas horizontalement et
verticalement c'est juste exceptionnel
jean louis etienne il a tout fait dans
sa vie il a 72 ans aujourd'hui et nous
dit moi 72 ans je veux aller voir
comment se passe la biodiversité
aujourd'hui redondant dans l'océan
cirque ou polaire en 10 secondes pour
terminer
est-ce qu'il est prévu une suite lasser
les personnalités françaises peut être
les personnalités interne international
pardon oui on l'objectif c'est de
montrer que finalement c'est pas rendre
possible l'impossible c'est rendre
possible l'impossible je prends le cas
de barack obama obama je prends le cas
de rodger federer qui feront partie du
futur ouvrage que nous rédigerons avec
notre ami arnaud bûcher revirer merci
karl olive d'avoir été avec nous au
maire de poissy coauteur du livre rendre
possible l'impossible c'est disponible
aux éditions emballant au prix à 2 19
euros
voilà c'est la fin du set 8 journal dans
un instant retrouver toutes les idées de
sorties du week-end dans le 7-8 loisirs
de marylène iapichino belle soirée avec
tv 78
[Musique]